before I do the straight integration I'm
just gonna make that fraction there I
might leave that bit of working just for
me because I don't need all of that
space immediately I'm just going to
manipulate this a teeny bit to make a
bit easier to work with so the first
thing I notice is this one on to why I'm
gonna write it as 1/2 times 1 on why cuz
that one on wise are very simple
integrand to deal with and then here
what do I want well when I am when I'm
integrating something which becomes a
log what I'm searching for is f dash on
F now that's not quite F dash if this is
my F if that's my function that f dash
should be negative 5 now I almost have
negative 5 here all I have to do is take
out a factor of negative 1/2 because of
that 2 so that's exactly what I'm gonna
do I'm gonna take out a negative 1/2 and
what that leaves me with is instead of 5
I've now got negative 5 on the top 1
minus 5y there we go and if you go ahead
and you expand that cancel your
negatives you should end up back here
everything is the same it's all with
respect to Y conveniently I noticed that
there's a half factor here which I can
take out salt do that and now we're
pretty much ready to integrate you will
notice I'm preserving that double
negative because it allows me to have F
dash on F which I want so now I'll
integrate so this is by the way this is
all equal to X that's the where I
started with right so there's X 1/2 okay
what do we get here now this is an
indefinite integral so I'm gonna get a
constant integration but no problem
because I'm looking for the general
solution after all so I'll leave that
constant there no big deal wah oh I've
already integrated so I don't need to
say one on Y anymore I can say that log
of Y what if I go to here minus log of 1
minus 5y that's all in there plus C ok
happy times so now what can I do here
well this mess here
I've done in some senses have done all
the calculus I've done all the
integration here I've got my plus C
that's already been handled
all that remains really to get from this
to the final answer is I want to get
this reminder with one's the subject and
as a function of X rather than as X is a
subject and a function of Y so really
there's just some rearrangement that
needs to happen at this point and you
need to know your log laws to be careful
with that so let's have a look at what
unfolds I can see there's a half there
so I'm gonna multiply everything by two
now I will just point out this constant
here it's just any number right so I'm
just gonna call it c1 the reason why is
because when I multiply everything by
two that gives me 2x I'm gonna lose the
half here so it gives me log Y minus log
of 1 that's 5 y this guy here I could
call it 2 times C 1 but 2 times a
constant is just another constant and I
don't really care what it is because I
just want the general solution so just
to make things easier for me to write
because mathematicians are famously lazy
I'm just going to call that senior where
C is well it's 2 lots of whatever that
other constant was and both of them are
just constants and I'll never work out I
don't have enough information from the
question to work out what the value is
and I don't need to so I'm just gonna
leave that as a label okay now I'm gonna
do two pieces of rearrangement at the
same time firstly I want to get all the
Y's by by themselves on their own so
that plus C is a bit of a pest so I'm
gonna put it over here I'll subtract it
from both sides and at the same time I
have to log terms and there's a
subtraction in between here so what I
can do is write this as a single log
term log off and use my log Wars
subtraction of logs whoops is division
of the terms inside so I'm going to say
why there's that over 1 minus 5y okay
we're on the homestretch now so I want
to get I want to disentangle those wise
out from inside the long term so I'm
gonna raise everything to the power of E
or e to the power of everything else and
that leaves me with this 1 minus 5y and
all I need to do is now just sort of
expand out and rearrange terms so if I
multiply this side by 1 minus 5y I'll
get one of
and then I'll get minus 5y of them so
that's e to the 2x minus C that's equal
to Y let's add this to both sides so I
can gather all my wires in one place so
that leads me where this equals y minus
5 lots of I should put the Y lasts
that'll make it easier to factorize
let's see here so I can make I can take
out Y as a factor well that should have
a minus sign around it yeah we're down
here I've gotten a bit I've done too
many things at the same time and talked
too much
I've actually added this to both sides
so that's just a Y outside of that and
that's added on the end because I added
this to both sides and you can see I've
put that five there so I can write this
next step a little easier 2x minus c
plus one of them that's many Y's I have
over there this guy's still hanging out
and now I just need to divide everything
by this make Y the subject so it looks
like I'm getting this guy 5 e to the 2x
minus c plus one happy times so there we
go
after affirmative work that is my
solution I have what did I do to start
with I took the reciprocals of both
sides because I saw that I couldn't
integrate as it was that's asking me to
integral with respect to X this is not a
function of X so I turn everything
upside down so I could integrate with
respect to the right variable but once I
did that I ended up with something which
I couldn't immediately integrate I I
didn't recognize that form and so I
needed to break this apart into two
separate fractions using partial
fractions so that these two fractions
now can be dealt with they just became
logs I got to this point here and having
integrated successfully all I need to do
is be careful with my terms which I
struggled with down the bottom here had
all the important bits be carefully
determine rearrange to make y the
subject rather than X and just as to
finish off right one of the great things
about this part of calculus is that
you know I had no answer key for this
particular question but I don't need one
because the original question provides
me everything if this really is the
answer then all I need to do is to
verify whether it's correct is I can
differentiate this and it should be
equal it should come out to this so for
example this guy here of this another
college just to highlight that it's
different if I take the derivative of
this function I'll call this you call
this V it's a little bit messy but I can
still do it the question formula is
going to tell me if this is V so that's
five e to the 2x minus c plus 1 v u - so
in this case you - will be 2 e to the 2x
minus c plus minus minus u which is
either 2 X - C V - so down here you can
see when I differentiate this guy that 2
is going to become at the front so
that's going to be 10 lots of e to the
2x minus C that gives me this term when
I differentiate that the derivative of 1
is just 0 so I just get that there's my
V u - - UV - all over V squared which is
going to be this monstrous disaster
which is no point expanding you can see
up here what's going to happen well
conveniently if you have a look at that
5 times 2 that gives you 10 and it's
going to give you an e to the 2x minus C
and another e to the 2x minus C you can
see that very neatly cancels with that
10 and that e to the 2x minus e to the
2x minus C or you get left to it after
those guys cancel cancel cancel is this
guy on the numerator so 2 e to the 2x
minus C on sir
mm-hmm there's my V squared and I will
leave it as an exercise to the reader to
go ahead and this is dy DX so I've just
tested the left hand side of my original
result over here and if you take what I
think the answer is and pop it into here
just substitute name
and just do some canceling if your
answer agrees is mine you should also
get that matching up
so hope you find that helpful